TITLE 42 DOES DROP.
NOW BACK TO YOU.
>> BILL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S GET THE READ ON THIS FROM
LIEUTENANT CHRIS OLIVERAS FROM
THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY.
CHRIS, THE CLOCK IS TICKING.
I'M INTRIGUED BE I THE TENT CITY
TO HOLD 500 PEOPLE FROM.
WHAT I'VE READ, THERE'S 1.8
MILLION EXPULSIONS SINCE TITLE
42 WENT INTO OPERATIONS.
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THAT'S ENOUGH
SPACE TO HANDLE THE DELUGE
EXPECTED.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHARLES.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING THERE WHAT
BILL MELUGIN JUST REPORTED ON
THAT, WHAT THEY'RE DOING,
THEY'RE DEPLETING FEDERAL
RESOURCES.
NOW YOU HAVE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AND STAFF.
ALL IT WILL MEAN IT WILL
ENCOURAGE THE IMMIGRANTS TO
CONTINUE TO COME ACROSS IN TO
THE UNITED STATES.
SO ALL THE VIDEO TAKING PLACE
THERE, THE VAST AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS, THAT'S LESS THAN
A MILE OF AN AREA WHAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON AS A STATE IS
WORKING WITH OUR INTERNATIONAL
PARTNERS IN MEXICO SO THAT THEY
CAN TAKE A MORE AGGRESSIVE SURGE
OF RESOURCES AND CONTAIN THE
GROUPS THAT ARE COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER ON THE MEXICAN SIDE.
>> Charles: HOW CONFIDENT ARE
YOU THAT THAT WILL HAPPEN?
>> CHARLES, EVER SINCE GOVERNOR
ABBOTT INITIATED THOSE
AGREEMENTS WITH THE GOVERNOR OF
MEXICO AND WE STARTED THE
ENHANCED SAFETY VEHICLE
INSPECTIONS, WE SAW WHAT TOOK
PLACE AT THE PORT OF ENTRY.
IT FORCED MEXICO TO SURGE
RESOURCES.
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW IT'S NOT
WORKING OR THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES IN PLACE.
WITH OUR STATE LEADERSHIP WITH
OUR AGENCY, HAVING SPECIFIC
CONVERSATIONS WITH MEXICAN
AUTHORITIES AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE BINATIONAL OPERATIONS
WITHOUT THE SOUTHERN BORDER IN
DEL RIO, LAREDO TO FOCUS ON
THESE PORTS OF ENTRY.
>> Charles: SO ALEJANDRO
MAYORKAS WAS TALKING ABOUT HOW
THE ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
DEAL WITH THIS.
TAKE A LISTEN, CHRIS.
>> BACK IN SEPTEMBER OF LAST
YEAR WE STARTED TO PLAN AND
PREPARE FOR THE EVENTUAL END OF
THIS CDC'S USE OF TITLE 42.
THAT IS IN FACT WHAT WE HAVE
DONE.
I'M GOING TO GO DOWN TO McALLEN,
TEXAS TOMORROW.
IT'S MY NINTH OR TENTH VISIT TO
THE BORDER AND EXPLAIN TO LOCAL
OFFICIALS EXACTLY WHAT OUR PLANS
AND PREPARATIONS INVOLVE.
>> Charles: CHRIS, FIRST OFF,
YOU'RE GOING TO BE SEEING
SECRETARY MAYORKAS.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO HEAR FROM
HIM?
>> WELL, CHARLES, WE'VE BEEN
HEARING THE CONVERSATIONS,
EVERYTHING WHEN THIS TOOK PLACE
ABOUT HAVING A PLAN IN PLACE.
WELL, IT'S ONE THING TO HAVE A
PLAN ON PAPER.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE AN AGGRESSIVE
STANCE.
TAKE PROACTIVE MEASURES AND
FOCUS ON THE ISSUES.
THAT'S MORE CONCERN.
LAST YEAR WE HAD 17,000 SURGE
THE BORDER AT ONCE.
BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE DONE AS A
STATE BY PROVIDING THE RESOURCES
WITH THE NATIONAL GUARD, WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DETER ANY OTHER
CARAVANS FROM MAKING THEIR WAY
TO THE BORDER, A QUESTION I
WOULD HAVE AND SHOULD BE
ANSWERED, WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO
PUT THIS PLAN IN PLACE AND TAKE
A STANCE, MORE AGGRESSIVE STANCE
IN SECURING THE BORDER,
PROTECTING THE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES, PROVIDING RESOURCES
TO BOARD TO FOCUS ON WHAT
THEY'RE GOOD AT.
SECURING THE BORDER, GOING AFTER
DRUG SMUGGLERS.
AS WE CONTINUE GOING FORWARD,
HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS WITH
MEXICO.
>> Charles: DO YOU PLAN TO SEE
SECRETARY MAYORKAS TOMORROW?
>> I WON'T BE IN THE VALLEY.
I'M IN WEST TEXAS RIGHT NOW.
I'M HERE COVERING OTHER ELEMENTS
TAKING PLACE HERE.
A DIFFERENT ELEMENT HERE IN WEST
TEXAS AS FAR AS BORDER SECURITY.
I'M CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT COMES
OUT OF THAT CONVERSATION.
>> Charles: YOU AND A LOT OF
DEMOCRAT